Baptist churches in Paducah Kentucky
which was the site of a high school
shooting back in 1997 are hosting quote
Second Amendment celebrations and
keeping away guns and stakes because you
got to have a stake if you're gonna have
a gun to attract more people to their
congregations I am not making this story
up it is actually true let's take a look
a little video from the local Fox
affiliate forgive me but I never really
heard of churches giving our guns and
get guys to sit in the pews oh man you
just been out of touch you
we've been doing this 20 years this
isn't Paducah you know Paducah Kentucky
you know what happened in Paducah I've
heard about that so did you know about
that before you plan is little ironic a
little we didn't sensitive the the issue
is not the guns the issue is men's
hearts and men who have their hearts
changed through a personal relationship
with Jesus Christ will handle guns
responsibly Chuck doesn't seem like a
very spiritual guy doesn't he well don't
worry folks it's not just happening in
Kentucky it's happening in New York to
upstate Troy New York according to the
LA Times there's a church there that's
giving away an assault rifle this very
weekend we've got the flyer yeah you can
win a free ar-15 my peace I give unto
you John 14:27
March 23rd yeah they're gonna give away
freaking assault rifle I mean is this
literally just the worst of everything
in America like somehow that they've
combined spirituality and religion and
guns and fear and go to state it's like
Jesus always say attorney of the cheek
and reload and then fire but like how do
you like how weak do you think your
stance is or your God is if you have to
attract people with guns like if your
message if you believe that heavily in
Jesus Christ and the love of the Lord
and you can't do it with the Bible right
yeah you have okay here's a gun here's a
stake what do I have to give you here's
two tickets to st. vitus our carnival
didn't work
mordioux how do I get you to love my
lord right and I guess religion in a way
is often about bribery one way or
another can use that gunpoint yeah the
Bible is like the shield for the bullets
and then you got your gun and the steak
what I was watching this I was thinking
look if a Jewish temple did this that
would just simply never happen and can
you imagine if I'm asked if Muslims said
we were giving away guns people would
the people's heads we should just try
that I think it see what happens you're
just really can you imagine their minds
Fox would literally spin off another
channel altogether to just deal with
that constantly because the rest I mean
but you know I bet there's a lot of
other churches and congregations and NRA
so we're rallying around these churches
who when people are you know crying that
this is a bad idea or this is you know
unpolitical or whatever there are
probably churches out there who are
coming around they're saying like we
should protect our you know our rights
and this is something that a church can
do but yeah god forbid if it was a
mosque it would be the other into the
ground how is it the heart test how does
that work when giving someone a gun yes
they have a good heart it's like it's
like the time when Bush said he looked
into Putin's eyes and saw into his like
someone to his heart like okay so their
beautifully so okay so the quote there
was my peace I give unto you and that's
so they're using a biblical term right
to try to sell you a gun but what's the
connection
yeah it's the other piece no but really
like what what are they going for there
like I I guess somehow they're implying
my peace I give it you in that I'm gonna
weaponize you so you will protect
yourself because I guess God can't
protect you when it comes down to it if
someone's breaking into your house he's
too busy picking is gonna win the final
four you got arm yourself and especially
for ya yeah I mean it's justice it's one
of those stories that it comes out and
you have nothing to say it's so it's so
terrible and you go this is I mean you
know this is a snapshot of America today
and it's it's it's it's terrifying and
maybe what's worse is they're giving out
this steak which is probably so pumped
full of hormones
we'll get this food stuff later yeah
yeah it's all GMO and all that stuff
alright so just to finish up with this
where do you guys generally stand on on
the gun thing I've been trying to ask a
lot of the panelists that we've had on
just a general thing because I feel like
our debate about it is so stupid so let
me get to rational people where do you
generally stand on the gun thing well I
think as a country we are so far gone
over the Second Amendment that taking
away guns is never gonna happen
so I think you really just need really
good rationale gun reform and that's all
you can really do here like you're never
gonna be Australia or England because
people will go crazy if you tell them
we're gonna get rid of guns so I think
it really comes down to just really good
solid reform so that people can have
them but maybe not a machine gun but you
could have a rifle to shoot a deer so I
mean I I have a family who is in Maine
who are hunters and they rely on that
for their food in the winter so I can't
be so against their ability to be able
to hunt but I think when the Second
Amendment was written it was like
muskets that they were talking about
right so maybe people should be able to
have a musket if you have to put there's
a powder and the mercial or the guy try
to do an office shooting with the muskie
that was a joke while he was reloading
everyone was gone right musket is the
argument against that though that these
people genuinely think that one day
they're gonna have to form a militia to
fight the government so they would argue
well that the government has tanks we do
need machine watch too much TV they're
watching movies they're like they're
losing the bunker those people Doomsday
Preppers like they're going nuts driving
themselves and saying with this crazy
illusion tomorrow we're gonna be big I
honestly believe that if the gun if the
NRA would like team up with like the
walking dead people and sell it to me as
you're gonna need this for the zombie
invasion I would be much more pro-gun
than I am right how many do you need how
many guns do you need only depends how
many ar-15 to hunt a zombie that's my
point